herzlich willkommen zur tennis welt
heute habt ihr seid ihr beim ersten teil
unserer fünfteiligen reise durch die
türkei
wir zeigen euch land menschen und kultur
und natürlich auch produktionsstätten
von unseren produkten lassen vieles hier
in deutschland regionalen hersteller
aber auch in der türkei
[Musik]
und heute geht es ums thema gusseisen
sind ab jetzt genau erhält nicht bildet
um 1 gefallen jetzt nicht so im shop
gehen sondern schaut euch das video an
damit ihr wisst um was es geht und bei
dem thema gusseisen kam mir vor zwei
jahren darauf vor zwei jahren die zellen
video gemacht über das thema ein
schmorbraten und viele kommentare unter
den videos war einfach so wo bekommt man
so ein sport her da kam eine frau auf
die idee und hat gesagt wir müssen
unbedingt einen schmortopf herstellen
was ganz ganz besonderes unsere eigene
sport töpfe die anders aussehen als alle
anderen auch in der funktion anders sind
ein bisschen anders aber vor allem auch
vom design her so dann haben wir uns
einfach verschiedene hersteller genommen
haben und sie sich angeschaut und
allgemein gusseisen tipp für angeschaut
und haben gemerkt dass ich immer gleich
aus und am körper mal gedacht wollen wir
dinge machen dass man wenn man unser
produkt so vollzieht das ist ein sally
topf wir haben noch nie sachen
produziert wir sind totale greenhorns
total leute die sowas noch nie gemacht
haben deswegen machen wir das nicht
immer mit einem anderen
betrachtungsweise wir haben wir sind
dahin gegangen
sie haben ab und die wolken haben sich
hingesetzt mit der sense zusammen haben
dann am programm einem grafikprogramm
sachen entworfen und das ist dabei
rausgekommen
unsere köpfe und zwar mit diesen riefen
an der seite doch genau hier zum
beispiel soll das besondere an diesen
riegel oder seile sind diese streifen
oder seien diese wirkungen sind wie es
etwas ganz ganz besonderes ist fällt
sofort auf das hat keiner auf dieser
welt dann haben wir drei oder vier
zusammen mit der zelle zusammen ist
immer nach frankfurt auf die messe und
haben uns verschiedene hersteller
vorgestellt
wir sind dann ich wusste natürlich dass
solche köpfe aus frankreich kommt zu den
franzosen gegangen dann habe ich gesagt
guck mal leute ich möchte diesen top wir
haben das sagen meistens ist es so dass
uns die hersteller wegschicken weil wir
viel zu klein sind und nicht diese
riesen stück mengen haben
aber dieser fraktion hat sich unsere
bilder angeschaut war wissen erstaunt
und hat gesagt das ist gar nicht möglich
hat mich folgenden grund wenn du diese
riefen an der seite hast kommt die
presse von oben sorgen die presserunde
und wenn du diese riefen hast kann die
presse nicht mehr raus damit dann hängen
bleiben
der franzose zu uns gesagt erzählt euch
es ist gar nicht möglich macht sich vom
acker so richtig genau da sind wir zum
thomas
unserem deutschen lieferanten und habe
gesagt oh was kannst du uns diesen top 4
machen
der turm hat diesen top hier angeschaut
hat sich mühe gegeben hatten versucht zu
erklären hat gesagt das ist nicht
möglich die presse kommt von oben bleibt
hängen richtig so und danach aber gesagt
deutsche kannst dich der franzose kann
es nicht geben chinesen zum video ist
ein guter freund von mir hallo william
so oder so was ihn wiederhaben abily an
kannst du das machen dann hat er will
sie das alles angeschaut und hat gesagt
schickt mir den kopf ich kopieren dir da
sag ich will ihm den topf gibt es gar
nicht da sagt dazu wenn es daher wenn es
der franzose nicht kann hat er deutsch
und ich kann und der chinese nicht
kopieren kann
dann gibt es diesen topf gar nicht und
so einmal ein bisschen enttäuscht wir
alle zusammen da haben wir gedacht
kommen jetzt laufen noch ein bisschen
rum vielleicht passiert ja was das immer
in das untere stockwerk und da war ein
typisches scheint an diesem stück stand
stand 1 million richtig genau oder
yussuf ayila yussuf aber sieht außer den
medien ist ein ganz ganz lieber adretter
herr mittleren alters ein ganz toller
typ haben gesagt jozefa w guck dir mal
das hier an optimal dass hier an kannst
du das machen
drei verschiedene größen einmal er lade
meine tochter einmal samira wie meine
tochter und einmal ali mit richtig
schwimmen da liebe genau dass sich der
user videos angeschaut und sagt dann zu
mir sagt er nur welche farbe
demonstration uns gesagt auf türkisch
wir sind auf dem boden gelegen vor
lachen wir haben uns nicht mehr gekriegt
damals am bauch gekrault weil eigentlich
wusste mir das sagt ja weil der türke
bin immer ist sage ich kann es nicht
der wird's dann machen und auch wer das
nicht hinkriegt habe gesagt ich hab's
hingekriegt richtig genau auf jeden fall
habe gesagt sagen oder welche farbe wir
haben uns tot gelacht und haben uns den
tee getrunken bei ihnen ist abgehauen
zwei wochen später kommen anrufe von
houston habe jungs ich habe es
hingekriegt wir haben es nicht geglaubt
richtig unmöglich keiner trägt sich aber
er hat sich gericht keinen spaß
und zwar hat eine presse gebaut die
einmal von oben kommt und ein mal
seitlich unglaublich ist eine absolute
weltneuheit ihr werdet es jetzt gleich
im film sehen wobei der josch die
sequenz weggeschnitten hat sollte man
das sagen wir können ja genau so sieht
der top hits aus ist der kleine der ist
jetzt von der l dieser bus stop ein
hammer ding und eine große brille auch
gleich zeigt vulkan habe den großen
bräter ordnung aus
und das ist der große bretter eine
absolute weltneuheit ein krasses ding
und das haben wir gemacht aus waghäusel
die fünf besten blick hat so auf jeden
fall so lange krieg im kreis hätte und
wie er das gemacht hat er schon
insgesamt oder gegen die türkei mit papa
zusammen und schauen sie also auf geht's
so mein papa zusammen wir sind
angekommen in der gießerei und für mich
ist einfach wichtig dass jetzt sie sowas
hergestellt wird
wer den menschen dahinter sind und wie
es gemacht wird wie show erzählt habe
hier sollte wissen basten produkt ihr
erhaltet ja und natürlich haben alle
sicherheitsvorschriften der papa hat
hier das model hat einen hut auch ein
helm auf dann haben wir hier natürlich
damit nicht schmutzig wird weil es ist
eine ganz ganz schmutzige angelegenheit
was wir jetzt machen hat er hier eine
jacke an jäckchen und sicherheitsschuhe
ich habe ja verfahrensmechaniker gelernt
haben menschen gearbeitet holz war es
wirklich immer so wenn besucher kommen
von außerhalb
da wurde alles richtig sauber geputzt
und allem drum und dran und die leute
meistens gekommen ihren krawatten der
ganze besuch und hat sich dann alles
angeschaut und wir haben gearbeitet und
ich fand dass jemand etwas blöd weil das
sei immer so aus wir haben auf uns
runter geschaut so auf die art und weise
wie wir gearbeitet haben und ich möchte
es hier nicht haben
ich möchte jetzt ich möchte nicht dass
die menschen denken war jetzt kommen die
grossen aus deutschland und und schauen
sich alles an das muss alles immer
perfekt sein
wir schauen das möchte ich nicht
deswegen habe ich folgendes gemacht ich
habe hier meine dreckige arbeit
vorgenommen ich möchte dass die menschen
einfach das gefühl haben ist der gehört
zu uns
das soll nicht sein ich arbeite jeden
tag gern mit dieser hose das ist meine
frau hasst diese hose und deswegen ziehe
jetzt um und dann gehen wir rein und
schauen sie mal die schießerei an
so jetzt so sehen jetzt aus und jetzt zu
ein bisschen mitarbeiter mal gespannt ob
sie nicht brauchen können so jetzt kämen
in die fabrik es ist kein schöner
arbeitsplatz es ist ein harter
arbeitsplatz es ist wahr es ist auch
teilweise gefährlich mit gießerei in
diese reihe ist kein spielplatz und
und jetzt fangen wir an in der ersten
station und zwar gegen martin formen
weil in formeln erzähle ich euch mal was
diese proben wird nachher der werkstoff
das eisen gegossen und diese formen
haben extra für uns produzieren lassen
und wir haben ja drei töpfe und jeder
tropfen hat vier formen und zwar einmal
das untere zwei mal wenn du brauchst im
oktober unterteilen und natürlich auch
beim deckel oberteilen und ihr müsst
euch eins vorstellen
jede form jedes denkmal wissen kost 8000
euro wir haben drei töpfe a4 formen sind
zwölf formen 8000 euro dann wisst ihr
was eine gigantische investitionen es
eigentlich ist haben wir wollten einfach
unserer eigenen haben und nicht einfach
unseren namen drauf schreiben
das heißt die ganzen formen und allem
was wir sehen ist unser material ist
gehört auch uns und diese farben
verwenden die nachher für die busreisen
für herstellung und diese performance
sind alles für den topf sanierer
hier haben wir die köpfe von der mama
das heißt die form von der mama und eine
form haben sehr eingespannt in die
presse und wie das punkt wie der presse
dass sie erst die form die preston
negativen der sand und dieser sand wird
einfach aufgefüllt mit gusseisen
[Musik]
ganz schön laut
[Applaus]
ihr habt es nicht ganz genau gesehen
dass mit der presse funktioniert das
dafür zeigen da gibt es ein kleines
geheimnis weil wir sonst die form und
andere komponenten
es ist eigentlich genial einfach aber
das möchte immer gern gehalten
das ist der rohstoff aus den kreisen
lippe gemacht haben ganz normale reisen
und hier wird nur im primären rohstoff
benutzt und kein sekundärer das heißt
kein recycling material sagt im
vordergrund es ist das garantiert
einfach die reinheit weiß ganz genau was
drin ist wenn wir noch recyclingmaterial
reinstecken würde dann müssten wir nicht
was nun stoppt man noch zusätzlich
heimmacht und da hat mit dem ding jetzt
gekocht wird ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir in reiner stoff ist und das ist
aus für diese cacau nimmst was diese
lieber benutzt
das ist so ein agent kann man so sagen
und dieser tage devils eingeschmolzen
das material ist muss eisen die köpfe
haben meint üblichen war wichtig das
material zusammen gesetzt und die
richtige ist wenn die falsche
materialzusammensetzung hast dann kann
es sein dass hatte boston das möchte man
nicht und da achten die extrem drauf das
ist immer die gleiche material
zusammensetzen
das heißt nun premiere stoff ein
jesus ganze material geschmolzen
1470 grad das ist das tor zur hölle
[Musik]
ich habe respekt vor den jungs ist ja
jeden tag machen das ist wirklich ein
arzt wird noch nicht ob es staubig
dieses treffen wie es heißt und man muss
eben jeder handgriff muss sitzen weil es
immer auch gefährlich ist was später mit
mittel mit heißen wie
sie soll sagen im heißen eisen und das
ist ständig aufpassen
die sicherheit ist saumäßig wichtig man
ist hier ein team zusammen und all diese
leute ja aber auch familie und wie
gesagt für mich ist wichtig dass ich mal
dabei bin dann sehen wie so was
hergestellt und auch für euch das nicht
so eine massenproduktion ist sagt zack
zack zack zack
hier ist wirkliches handwerk dabei ich
bin richtig stolz auf die jungs aus
kreisen
also ich hab preise sondern auf sie
aufpassen die jungs und er hat mich
gerade gefragt wenn mit seiner familie
anschauen möchte man es ausgestrahlt und
ich habe es auch in zwei drei wochen
ausgestrahlt auf youtube und ich toll
was die amerikaner haas ältestes habe
ganz coole jungs wirklich so hier ist
jeder block ist hier ein hohlkörper und
in diesen hohlkörper kommt mit jetzt
dieses gusseisen eingefüllt und dann
rutscht ist immer weiter und das ist
eine ganz ganz lange strecke und ganz
zum schluss kühlt das ding ab oder kommt
davon ausgeht und wie diskus schauen uns
jetzt gleich an
[Musik]
so
es ist was los ist
gracias dem wahnsinn dass ich das mal
machen so das ist richtig heftig ich
weiß nicht wer der mann ist aber würden
manchmal so mitte fünfzig sein und es
ist wirklich heftig das ding zu erheben
wahnsinnig darauf merkt ein bisschen
fingerspitzengefühl so ich muss ehrlich
sagen ihr habt ein bisschen pipi in der
hose gehabt ein bisschen angst gekauft
ich habe mich da lieber raus wie sollen
sie machen
die profi ist also absolut ihr seht ihr
das 1000 grad heisse eisen ist es jetzt
einige leute jetzt auch noch und es band
cheap immer weiter vor und um soweit es
bank weiter vorschiebt kühlt immer mehr
ab und ich die immer weiter nach hinten
gesehen habe verändert sich und hier zb
sieht das leuchten gar nicht mehr hier
schön hier schon klar phase man merkt
auch diesen bisschen aussehen
der ganze sand und jetzt immer weiter
und brice am schluss ende am ende der
kette
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt die formel der sanft
gerundet recycelte reisende wieder
verringert
die frauen hier
unser weg woran liegend oder stehend
die decke wird jetzt
in der zweiten reihe wird sauber gemacht
das ist jetzt der decke man sieht noch
nicht so ganz genau was es sein soll
aber das kommt jetzt nicht live wird
richtig sauber gemacht und lackieren und
dazu müssen auch ein anderes gebäude so
in meinem früheren beruf habe ich auch
mal labor messwerte nehmen müssen von
wasser von den ganzen rohstoffen und
jeder topf hat hier so ein chip und
dieser chip thomas mit dem
spektralphotometer um jetzt messen und
dass wir wissen was für inhaltsstoffe da
drin sind
das ist ganz ganz wichtig dann haben wir
hier vergleicht was es sein da ab dem
sommer denn ist wer hier zum beispiel j
bin immer hier rein gehst du zb
kohlenstoff zwischen 340 und 350
situation zwischen 240 250 mangan
phosphor schwefel chrom nickel kupfer
aluminium titanium und was heißt es es
noch man ist ja nicht mehr muss in atens
nachschaut nicht voll cool ich kenne
auch die ganzen abkürzungen und dadurch
ein spektakulum jetzt geschaut was alles
drin ist und wenn er hier oben re
unregelmäßigkeiten drin sind dann wird
dieses protein ist natürlich nicht
hergestellt geht nicht in den verkauf
geht nicht raus und die dame jetzt hier
im hintergrund die schau mal nach ob wir
in diesen ist und in diesen sollwert und
prinz entspannt ist jetzt ein
und das ist immer gleich auf dem
bildschirm wie die werte sind
so jetzt sind wir hier oben schon mal
die werte kohlenstoff 3,46 perfekt ist
absolut zwischen 3,4 und 3,51 lithium
mangan phosphor schwefel magnesium pro
michael nickel ist nicht gut
bis zum gewissen punkt dann haben wir
hier kupfer alle videoportal
und so wie es jetzt aussieht ich schaue
ich gerne mal an das alles sind den
sollwerten drin weil hier steht auch
grünbach heißt kannst weitermachen und
wenn es jetzt hier rot wir haben
pass auf - zeug wieder raus mach es
nochmal so hier wird das eisen hier
geschnitten mit einem diamanten richtig
schön
so soll die glatte oberfläche muss es
sein und jetzt schaue ich mir das noch
mal an und mikroskopisch waren es ja
auch noch mal um einfach die struktur
noch mal anzuschauen wie sie das eisen
aus wie soll es aussehen und allem drum
und dran
es kommt jetzt unters mikroskop und dann
gucken wir mal
so sieht das bild jetzt aus das
schnittbild was ich habe oder mikroskop
da gibt es verschiedene klasse
beziehungen von abc und das ist klasse
1a also absolut tipptopp so wie es auch
sein muss und diese kontrollen machen
sie natürlich bei jedem produkt das
heißt bei jeder charge es gibt eine
charge rückverfolgung es gibt eine
nummer
das heißt sie wissen immer wann welcher
top wohin geliefert wurde ist ganz ganz
wichtig lassen jetzt die töpfe aus dem
ofen aus der presse jetzt hole ich die
gerade raus jetzt muss ich die sand
befreien ihr seht voll mit sand mit der
fonds jetzt einfach drauf stellen ob es
ein bisschen aus so soll sie jetzt aus
unterricht kommt jetzt in die sandstrahl
maschine natürlich einfach den wagen
hier bestücken
und dann geht es rein sandgestrahlten da
kommt picobello sauber wieder raus und
ich habe mir natürlich schon ein paar
vorbereitet
[Musik]
so jetzt kommen die schon fertig
sandgestrahlt ihr habe ich jetzt schon
freuen reingemacht und dessen die ganzen
dicke
so sieht jetzt aus wie copello sauber
und vom sand befreit
und jetzt geht es weiter zur veredelung
weil just über noch diese länder die wir
es alle komplett abgeschliffen dass hier
keine geräte mehr sind und so sieht der
top haus ist der deckel der bundes und
ihr seht jetzt der schock ist doch so
richtig rund jetzt hat er überall noch
scharfe kanten und die werden jetzt per
hand weggeschlagen ganz ganz wichtige
arbeit ist mache ich sie nicht und zwar
macht es der ärger habe
der ist nämlich der meister hierfür und
er macht das kratzen
[Musik]
das hier ist afrika wir und ich hab mich
mal jemand gefunden der kleiner ist als
ich gibt es auch noch und dafür damit
macht folgendes jetzt wurden ja die
griffe in drin komplett in gerader und
hier sehe ich auch ganz ganz böse
scharfe kanten und dafür dabei macht
jetzt folgendes der spannend jetzt
diesen top 4 1 und macht jede ganzen
ungeraden sachen ihr weg gerade scharfen
kanten hier komplett den ganzen top4
damit er richtig schön platt ist dafür
da wir in der sache hatte das macht er
will ich ganz in absolut profi macht
[Musik]
das hat jetzt darf er aber richtig schön
geschliffen das heißt keine scharfen
kanten mehr da ist aber noch nicht schön
und das waren jetzt wieder fächer
scheinen und zwar macht es da ahmed der
arbeit ist 28 jahre alt und arbeitet
fügt wir haben hier schon genauer hin
dass diesen penger schleifer und zwar
sieht es so aus und macht es hier noch
mal richtig glatt und tut es einfach
noch verfeinern
[Musik]
so jemand der schon mal mit hand gerade
taten mit einer flex der weiß wie viel
arbeit ist auch nicht ungefährlich muss
man ganz ganz ehrlich sagen und es ist
wirklich ein toller job und ihn so gut
so sein wird diese roboter geben das ist
ein roboter der ist übrigens made in
germany und diese roboter wird in
zukunft diesen menschen diese arbeit
abnehmen
und diese menschen diese nicht so tolle
arbeit gemacht haben oder machen die
werden sich darum kümmern um diese
roboter einzustellen um sie zu
kontrollieren
das ist einfach eine
arbeitserleichterung auch für die
menschen hier
und wie gesagt made in germany richtig
genial so jetzt mache ich einfach die
bohrung für den für den deckel weil da
muss ich nach den griff befestigen
[Musik]
perfekt jetzt bekommt das ding noch ein
richtig cooles peeling und dieses
peeling schafft man mit diesen
besonderen stein ich kann es nicht sagen
was man steine es ist ich weiß dass sie
sehr sehr teuer sind jetzt läuft hier am
rand läuft hier wasser runter und macht
das alles nur sauber das heißt sie
werden es in diesen steinen baden der
ganzen schmutz darunter gewaschen und es
wird sondern richtig wie sowieso eine
zweite haut ungefähr
und jetzt tue ich das einfach alles
bestücken hier habe ich auch noch eine
andere serie pfanne
es ist einfach ja die tümpel ist auch
hier ist das alles bestücken und dann
wird es richtig gerüttelt und dann fährt
es richtig in die steine rhein wieder
hoch wer richtig coole aktion schallte
es mal an
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt der letzte schliff ist
der letzte schliff in der schleiferei
und zwar das ist richtig krass ich kenne
es ja früher schon mal sandgestrahlt
aber es war wird nicht nur sand und das
da hier sind metall kügelchen
das sind ganz ganz feine kugeln und
diese kügelchen die werden jetzt auf
unser geschirr geschossen richtig
geschossen mit hohem druck und die
machen das letzte rest was noch möglich
ist eine feinheit dass es so richtig
glatt rauskommt die hängen jetzt gerade
hier so rein
[Musik]
aber krass wie es jetzt aussieht
wow so wie gesagt der letzte schliff
fertig und jetzt geht's weiter mit der
veredelung und zwar geht es in die
lackiererei
lackiert werden sie übrigens bis zu vier
mal
es kommt halt drauf und eine ganze lag
da kommt auch die majolika beschichtung
drauf da kommt nochmal drüber sondern
geht es zweimal in open das heißt bis
zur perfektion
ich glaube ich bin viel zu schnell für
die will wie ein kuka roboter
so die farben drei natürlich es ist
immer und immer wir müssen ganz salopp
sack ist eigentlich anderes als last da
wird ja sie das natürliche farben sind
die brüder aus deutschland kommt macht
nichts aus schmeckt jetzt nicht gerade
super habe ich über schwarze farbe auch
immer das macht nichts aus man kann die
farbe essener stx hämisches drin und
himmels wird jetzt lackiert wenn ihr
sollte mit kochen und backen können
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der erste schritt und
nachdem ein lackiert
doch unglaublich mit drei stücken
forstern mit ihrer riesigen open geht
und noch mal richtig hoch gehalten
und wie dann die türkei aus indem sie
fertig sind
thema gleich vorne
sollte ist ziemlich spät schon sind alle
schon nach hause gar nicht feierabend
und die töpfe sind fertig die sind noch
ein bisschen warm hier
und so sehen sie aus und wir haben hier
sechs verschiedene farben dass dieses
rot was wir haben uns richtig genial
ihr habt gesehen wie viel arbeit
dahintersteckt es ist aber noch nicht
fertig wirklich ist noch nicht fertig
jetzt nicht mal ein mit und schauen uns
mal den topf ganz genau an
so jetzt immer fertig und ihr seht was
mir aus diesen eisen hier produziert
haben zusammen in kaiser und wie viel
arbeit dahinter steckt die menschen
dahinter steckt wie viele handgriffe
dahinter stecken will stationen es ist
wirklich der wahnsinn hier direkt habe
er gesehen direkt ins gegossen wird aus
richtig aus eisen aus richtung reisen
dann geht es weiter hier wurde der topf
jetzt sand mit ihnen steigen gewaschen
in der in der schleiferei hier wurde er
sandgestrahlt dann wurde er hier wird
eine grundierung drauf gemacht und
zuletzt das emaille und habe gesehen ist
wird zwischen drei und fünf mal je nach
farbe lackiert was das für eine arbeit
ist das jetzt nur ein paar farben jetzt
fehlt noch der griff der it wird noch an
montiert aber wir sind jetzt immer nicht
fertig wir sind wirklich noch immer
nicht fertig die nächsten schritte das
heißt die ganze verpackung das
demontieren die qualitätskontrolle
die findet bei uns in oberndorf am
neckar statt und dort gehen wir jetzt
als nächstes hin
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir in deutschland und
zwar ganz genau in oberndorf am neckar
hier ist unser lager und hier verpacken
auch alles was die schüler hier macht
sie kontrolliert alles noch mal um
irgendwelche schrammen drin sind oder
irgendwelche flecken oder irgendwas
oberst noch dran ist das macht die hülle
ja hier ist sozusagen die endkontrolle
und die verpackung und das haben muss
sich nehmen lassen wenn man jeden
topeinzel kontrollieren möchten hier
haben wir den opa bernd und zwar der opa
bernd rentner ob hab ich recht jawohl
und der opa ist und alle sondern vier
jahren schon in der heißen alter rolling
stone alias nicht erst lohnt sondern
erst rolling stone
und das ist da der vater von der sabine
und er hilft uns natürlich dass man noch
hinterher kommen und schraubt hier
überall die ganzen deckel drauf die
ganzen griffe soll der opa ist sind
deckel draufgemacht oder hat den griff
und joschka mal ganz kurz er guckt jetzt
mal kurz an und das ist ein richtig
komplett hand gemacht hat ob jetzt hast
du ein paar lackierer einschüsse drin
das schlimme ist ja dadurch kostet ja
nicht so jetzt nämlich den top ranking
der volkan und das geht jetzt hin dass
verpackungen weiter verfangen haben uns
auch was überlegt und zwar haben wir
hier ein recyceln im kart und es ist
recycling material ohne verzichten
komplett auf kunststoffe das heißt bei
der verpackung nehmen wir richtig
holzwolle das war mord kann seine idee
kommt den natürlichen topf und auch eine
komplett natürlichen verpackung oder
findest du auch cool aus das kann man
für seine haustiere benutzen oder wenn
man grillt als grillanzünder benutzen
eine ganz coole geschichte
und jetzt kommt der top 4 1 perfekt
jetzt kommt er gerade hier rein
ok und als nächstes kommen wir hier so
sabine das heißt oft kontrolliert wir
haben den griffigen gemacht hier
eingelegt und jetzt kommt noch was ganz
besonderes entsteht uns zu sabine und
die sabine macht folgendes und zwar ich
möchte dass wenn die leute den topf auf
machen allein schon die verpackung in
der hand haben das ist ein aha erlebnis
ist jeder topf bekommt außer diesen sie
sind zertifikate garantie belegt bekommt
ihr hier und kontroll zertifikat dass
wir alles kontrolliert haben unten wachs
stempel und zwar haben wir hier cool und
die komplette mappe die sie nachher so
aus und zwar sehe hier die verschiedenen
zertifikate ist control zertifikat von
der sabine und hier seht die nummer 0
004 hier immer die karte
hier haben wir eine gebrauchsanleitung
ein rezept nicht dann haben wir ein
pflege hinweis eine garantiekarte alles
komplett ist mit drin und so kommt es
dann diese mappe kommt dann hier in den
topf 1
so jetzt gehts hier komplett zum papa
und es ist ja der gelbe topf und der
gelbe topf der bekommt jetzt hier ein
siegel aber macht es mal drauf hier
drauf grad
da müssen wir nachher im lager perfekt
das ist der level könnt jetzt ganz auf
reise gehen zu euch so das wird heute
abend ein bisschen später aber so
versuchen das hinzubekommen
und jetzt gehen wir zurück zu uns in die
küche und die sally erklärt euch
eigentlich überhaupt was sind die
besonderheiten eines gusseisen tops und
zeigte die ganze haben
und da gehen wir jetzt nach waghäusel so
jetzt bin ich bei sli in unserer küche
auch meine frau ja ja und es meinen
machen ja aber in wirklichkeit der luft
kann passieren
auf jeden fall das kannst du dich hier
verklären wir haben jetzt alles gemacht
design funktion alles herstellung
herstellung wer es gemacht hat und jetzt
erkläre ich warum man überhaupt die
köpfe braucht genau wie ich glaube dass
man vergessen zu sagen dass warum warum
kocht
und backt man überhaupt einen
gusseisernen töpfen großen topf das ist
so eine sache das kennt man vielleicht
noch von der oma oder von der mama das
sind diese leckeren eintopf wird die
schmorgerichte die brote die einfach
stunden lang im ofen sind und dann
einfach wirklich super automatisch
schmecken zum großen topf der ist auch
für den täglichen gebrauch aber nicht
wird schneller kochen denn gusseisen
wird wirklich schön langsam warm und
gibt dann die wärme über den längeren
zeitraum eben auch wieder ansgar gut ab
also könnt ihr wirklich hier drin schöne
vor gerichte machen uns gerade brot
bekommt zum beispiel eine unglaublich
leckere kruste
ich weiß nicht ob das gezeigt hast aber
der topfdeckel hat er im innern diese
noppen und die sorgen dafür dass es gar
gut wenn der topf heben fest
verschlossen ist
dann kommt das kondenswasser nach oben
steigt ihr in die höhe
kommt hier oben an diesen locken dran
und an den locken tropft dann wieder
herunter vielleicht ist genau ganz
gleichmäßig das heißt wenn ihr hier drin
ein brot backt dann wird es wirklich wie
in einem dampfbad offen ständig mit dem
kondenswasser wieder bewässert und
erhält dadurch die kruste und innen
bleibt aber schön saftig und der deckel
days auch wirklich extrem schwer so dass
er wirklich auch flach auflegt und wenn
ihr 13 schwurgericht drin habt und das
ganze im backofen ist dann riecht nur in
der küche auch nichts denn das ganze
aroma bleibt einfach hier schön in dem
topf alles hier drinnen die feuchtigkeit
bleibt drin und das aroma bleibt drinnen
und ich mache darin wirklich gerne
schmorgerichte ich mache aber auch
pfannengerichte fallen lassen jetzt zum
beispiel eignet sich auch hervorragend
brot backen kann man darin und auch ganz
tolle vegane gerichte zum beispiel haben
wir auch schon in wolken zusammen
gemacht genau allerdings wenn die
arthrose ab dh gelenkprobleme dann kann
es auch sein dass der topf ein bisschen
zu schwer ist die sind wirklich schwer
also sie sind so schon gesperrt deswegen
das sollten wir vielleicht wirklich dazu
sagen wenn dann noch ein bisschen inhalt
drin ist kann schon ein bisschen schwer
sein - kommt eingefahren ich muss die
samira am kindergarten abhole ich muss
jetzt weg da macht weiter nach weiteren
okay die samira ist nicht mehr im
kindergarten dies in der schule ja in
der mhh stehen ich muss sagen ich war
lange der türkei deswegen werde also ist
gleich jahres gleich ich mache so lange
weiter
und der vorteil bei meinem großen töpfen
ist ihr könnt sie auf allen härten und
im backofen benutzen
auch beim induktionsherd induktion gas
wirklich alle ceran kochfelder und
meistens mache ich es einfach so auf dem
herd
die röstaromen ab das heißt ich lebe
hier mein gemüse reihen das fleisch weit
und breit alles schön an und dann kommt
damit schön zart wird in den backofen
mit dem deckel und da kann es dann vor
sich hin sparen wir zeit wird
automatisch bei der oma war es früher so
irgendwann sah der gusseisernen topf
einfach nicht mehr so schön sauber aus
denn man kann wenn man möchte einfach
hier drinnen diese schicht ein bisschen
ein brennen lassen wie bei den
eisenbahnen da macht man ja auch diese
patina schicht so dass man wirklich auch
zum einen weniger fett braucht beim
anbraten denn es klebt dann nichts mehr
an
und zum anderen hat man einfach von mal
zu mal von jahr zu jahr immer mehr
geschmack im topf das kann man machen
muss man aber nicht also entweder macht
er wirklich die eine version dass er
sagt okay ich las es ein brennen wie bei
der oma früher dann habe ich einfach
schön das braten aroma mit drinnen und
wirklich von mal zu mal wird das gericht
besser oder ihr sagt ich bin eher so der
typ ich möchte doch gerne auswaschen
dann könnt ihr die großen töpfe wirklich
auch ganz einfach wieder auswaschen und
sie sehen nach jedem gebrauch wieder aus
wie neu
nach dem reinigen ist ganz wichtig dass
er dem großen topf nicht gleich
verschließt lasst ihn wirklich komplett
durch trocknen und dann erst mit dem
deckel verschließen
am besten bewahrt ihr sogar noch diese
transport clips auf die legt ihr dann
nach der reinigung und nach dem trocknen
auf den deckel auf und dann kann der
topf noch mal schön durchlüften
ich habe hier drei verschiedene modelle
dh drei verschiedene größen und formen
und ich habe es einfach nach den drei
frauen meines lebens bin nach den drei
wichtigsten frauen meines lebens und
zwar einmal meine mama die anime dass
hier der große gusseisen britta weil
meine mama eben auch diese gusseisen
gerichte macht also diese schmorgerichte
die saat auf der runde top heißt ella
ella ist super gerne eintöpfe und der
flache topf die pfanne
die heißt samira weil sie mir einfach
pfannengerichte lebt das ist jetzt
unsere gusseisen serie meine mama war
wirklich gerührt dass dieser gusseisen
britta nach ihr benannt wurde
der papa ist ganz stolz dass wir die
serie in der türkei haben herstellen
lassen und wir sind natürlich auch ganz
stolz drauf vielen dank noch mal an das
team in der türkei dank fab und es war
wirklich so wir haben alles gegeben
alles versucht und alle haben sie uns
gesagt ihr schafft das nicht ihr könnt
das nicht und dann kam einfach der josef
aber da wusste das nicht und hat einfach
gemacht
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
und ihr könnt wirklich schon gespannt
darauf sein
und auch die nächsten videos freuen timo
rath mit josh gemeinsam gedreht hatte
über unsere produktreihe bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss